Matakana machine code is the Yakuza
franchise is over a decade old and in
that time its feature set has
predictably grown over six main line
entries free roam Ares became more
substantial additional playable
protagonists were introduced combat
mechanics were expanded to incorporate
multiple fighting styles and more and
more minigames were steadily piled on
surprisingly the latest installment goes
the other way discarding components that
certainly won't go unnoticed by series
devotees but that doesn't end up being a
bad thing because it accuses six the
song of life successfully uses its
smaller footprint to create a deeper
more meaningful impression the song of
life centers on Keira as he returns from
another long stint in prison separated
from the Tojo clan and unravels the
mystery of an infant who suddenly come
into his care the setup distinctly echos
the events of the first game a seemingly
purposeful decision which lets the song
of life act as a nice refrain giving
Kira's final sojourn a roundness that
brings a solid sense of closure to his
series mark his investigations bring him
to the port town of Onomichi Hiroshima
where he encounters a lowly blue collar
crime family led by an aging but
supposedly legendary Yakuza portrayed by
Takeshi Kitano
while the game unsurprisingly spirals
into a complex and dramatic story
involving underworld political alliances
age-old conspiracies and a healthy dose
of deception was ultimately memorable
other threads and character developments
that explore what becomes a very
significant widespread theme family
bonds of friendship in the face of
adversity loyalty in times of
uncertainty and caring for your ward as
a parental figure these names are
consistent through the better parts of
the accuser Six's narrative and this
includes the numerous optional sub
stories you'll help children and parents
resolve conflicts and try to understand
each other's point of view and see Kiryu
finding different ways friends and
strangers can support one another the
writing in these stories is often corny
but that doesn't mean that there isn't
an endearing sincerity that regularly
shines through when the sentimental
piano melody kicks in during pivotal
scenes of moralistic resolution it's
hard not to be swept up by it all dr.
Ouma eco comedy varsity woman Dawson
Imam Antonio Dawson
Oh demo both uncritical avocado the
series's penchant for goofiness still
exists but it doesn't return to Yakuza
zero as ludicrous levels of absurdity
particularly memorable sub stories are
ones which humorously explore can use
our familiarity and disdain toward
modern technology like drones robot
vacuums and YouTube but even the game's
most comedic series of quests which
involves security dressing up is on
amici's adorable character mascot ends
up being a touching reflection about
having loyalty in town pride or do a
full enormity no sports rule no media
these heartwarming stories are also a
key component of Yakuza 6 as new
minigames there are less of these sad
activities in previous entries but much
of what's included is more robust than
usual and in many cases the sub stories
attached to them are enjoyable enough to
stop the simple mechanics wearing thin
too quickly spearfishing in the baseball
league are great examples of that but
the snack bar minigame stands out as a
real highlight this one involves
attempting to become a regular on a
small cheers style locals bar where kiri
tries to forge personal relationships
with a group of ordinary blue-collar
folk conversely there's the incredibly
involved clan creator mode which sees
Kure you unwittingly intervening in a
war between youth gangs whose leaders
include real-world new japan pro
wrestling why not I guess will take
leadership of one of these groups and
participate in simple realtime strategy
style street battles Clank Raiders Jack
oozes 6 his most substantial minigame
posting online network functions that
Lee compete against other players
tackled daily missions and participate
in a ranked ladder but unfortunately
it's also the most tedious to play
victory strategies dim entirely from
massing as many troops as possible and
battles don't ever really become
challenging until the sub story missions
are already done elsewhere on top of a
selection of Sega arcade classics there
are multi play capable versions of
puzzle action favorite CLE employer and
the seminal Virtua Fighter 5 final
showdown
both robust offerings in their own right
mahjong darts karaoke and a cat cafe
also appear as options
Yakuza 6 also maintains the series
convention of including more titillating
pursuits Cabaret club's return and
notable is the particularly risque live
chat I mean again which sees you
watching live-action webcam shows
featuring real world AV idols no less we
hit button prompts progressed to the
point we can
the model strip off their clothes and
moan suggestively the unambiguous
objectification of women in these
minigames continue to make their
inclusion uncomfortable in their own
right the presence does truthfully
reflect prominent parts of the
real-world Japanese nightlife and at all
industries but these kinds of minigames
have always been fetch awaited an
unbelievable inconsistency of character
vacu there's a conflict between the
canonical depiction of him as a strong
stoic honourable saint and a version who
is a really creepy bumbling perv the
series is distinct sense of vibrant true
to life play still remains when roaming
around in the camera chair or onomichi
and that's amplify about what feels like
a more details and densely populated
world there's a new element of
verticality with increased rooftop
access biagas are now also rewards you
for interacting with the world in a way
that previous games didn't eating at the
games many restaurants which was
previously really only worth doing if
you needed a health boost is now the
most convenient way to rack up
experience points to spend in the game's
extensive upgrade system though you're
limited by a new stomach capacity meter
purchasing and drinking beverages from
one of the numerous vending machines
around the world will give you cheap
temporary combat buffs and every
minigame from the batting cages to
playing around if super hang on will
also earn you experience the result is
that slowing down and taking your time
to soak in the atmosphere of the city
will benefit you and the wall there's no
longer just two pretty paths be to run
down to get to your next objective of
course Yakuza is an all casual fun and
game sometimes you need to pound some
dirtbags into the ground and the game's
updated combat system follows its
philosophy of slimming and focusing gone
are the variable fighting disciplines
introduced in yuccas 0 the key ryu of
Yakuza 6 is equipped only with an
expanded version of his signature
brawling style perhaps another refrain
to the series is beginnings it still
maintains that characteristic weight and
rigidity but there are additional
factors that make the active fighting
feel more fluid than it's been in the
past
turning encounters as a whole into more
dynamic exciting experiences enemy mobs
are larger in the song of life and crowd
control takes a more prominent focus
because of that set-piece fights that
make up the central story moments
regularly seek Uryu and his companions
go up against dozens upon dozens of
enemies at once
a ratio that is frequently amusing as a
result the properties of curious moves
have been altered his throw maneuver
swings
me around for letting them fly each
combat string now allows him to execute
to finishing blows as a default and the
second typically lunges forward with a
wide attack radius but the most
significant change to combat is that
benefits from seamless transitions
between world exploration and battles
you not locked into an area anymore and
fights have the potential to move
through the city and into areas like
stairwells rooftops convenience stores
restaurants and a handful of other
accessible building interiors it also
means you can make a break for it and
run if you're not in the mood to
throwdown
the dynamism and uninterrupted flow thus
gives users comment is a real wonder it
means that random battles are less
likely to eventually devolve into
monotony as they could have in past
games combat in Yakuza 6 is exciting and
the situations you might find yourself
in positively echo the kinds of scrappy
tense struggles you see so commonly in
East Asian gangster films
the one mechanic that doesn't really hit
the mark is the new rage system it
allows you to sacrifice the entire heat
gauge and by dealing and taking damage
for the limited ability to deal more
damage avoid being staggered and perform
unique heat actions
this series is entertainingly brutal
takedowns it's a useful tool on paper
but when it's activated the camera zooms
in way too close to qu and you lose too
much peripheral vision to make the
technique practical in crowd situations
or difficult one-on-one fights another
sticking point is one that's been
present in all of the games iterations
the inconsistent visual presentation
while the scenes that deliver pivotal
plot events are absolutely spectacular
with uncannily lifelike character models
dramatic cinematography and exceptional
japanese-language performances scenes
that present lesser moments like sub
stories are again a dramatic drop in
quality even though they're fully voiced
this time which goes a long way as in
previous games they still feature far
less detailed character models and
wooden sometimes not exist in animation
static camera angles also play a big
part in aggravating their dullness more
snow cooler that are all kiddin look
into my discipline yeah cos are six
reins in its scope it doubles down on
what makes the series great it's a
unique and fascinating representation of
the modern Japanese experience that's
worth playing even if you're a newcomer
the narrative is dramatic and sincere
and the game's endearing characters
coming from all walks of life are
interesting studies the wall is dense
and rewarding to exist in the dynamic
combat system stays exciting even off
you've kicked the crap out of 5,000
enemies and perhaps most importantly
yuccas is 6 the song of life serves as a
fulfilling conclusion to the turbulent
decade long saga of its beloved icon
Kazuma Kiryu door mr. Harker
dodeth or in a hotel kazakh integrity'
now what I'm uh sorry about the huskers
gonna use stoked